ich habe wieder mal gelesen dass die
briefwahl so bunt dass 60% man sich an
dieser wahl per briefwahl teilnehmen und
finde es irritierend dass es darüber
wenig diskussionen über die empörung
gibt weil ich finde brings wahlen in
dieser größenordnung ist undemokratisch
während mehr als die hälfte der menschen
sich so viel früher festlegen dann gibt
es ein verzerrtes bildes
wettbewerbsverzerrung und ich kann es
auch begründen sogar aus der idee einer
wahl heraus die sollen nämlich frei und
gleich sein geheim haug jetzt machen wir
mal bei frei ist sie geheimnis sie per
brief wahrscheinlich auch aber sie ist
nicht gleich weil zugleich gehört
natürlich auch der gleiche tag an dem
alle abstimmen wenn ich mir vorstelle
was jetzt bis zum 26 september noch
alles passieren kann was all diejenigen
die jetzt schon wählen gar nicht mehr in
ihre wahlentscheidung mit einbeziehen
können mache ich mir sorge ob da
überhaupt ein ergebnis rauskommt das mit
der realität wirklich etwas zu tun
ich finde das ziemlich rückwärtsgewandt
das so zu sehen weil ich was sind die
kennen die schweiz auch schon ein
bisschen weil ich dort gab es teilweise
und das funktioniert ganz wunderbar und
vor allem ein punkt bei der briefwahl
ist ja dass die die wahlbeteiligung
gesteigert wird und ich finde dass ein
totaler ist super für das individuum
selbst entscheiden können wann wählen
gehe ich sehe dem punkt dass man sich
vielleicht ja das ist halt so manche
dinge nicht wissen kann aber dann müsste
man vielleicht mit dem zeitraum sprechen
oder in dem eine wahl möglichen es gibt
aber ich finde
und die menge es gibt zum beispiel eine
klare erkenntnis darüber dass wenn alle
per brief wählen würden würde das
bundesverfassungsgericht damit nicht
konform gehen meine these lautet wenn es
60 prozent sind sind wir näher an alle
als an dem ursprungsgedanken dass jemand
der am wahltag weiß dass er nicht an
seinem ort ist oder der nicht ins
wahllokal gehen kann dafür war die
briefwahl ja ursprünglich gedacht ich
glaube dass sie in gewisser weise
zweckentfremdet ist und wir noch gar
nicht uns richtig klarmachen was das
bedeutet ich finde es ist auch ein
zeichen ungeheurer bequemlichkeit muss
ich sagen es gibt natürlich in kona zeit
ein gewisser argumente dafür man will da
nicht hin aber da würde ich sagen bei
unserer info und der machen ich sehe
noch beim bäcker an da kann man auch mal
im wahllokal angeht ich für mich die
schönste anekdote die schönste anekdote
über das wählen in den usa wird immer
dienstags gewählt weil sonntag kirche
ist und dann braucht man auch den montag
um zum nächsten wahllokal zu reiten und
deswegen wird am dienstag gewählt und
das zeigt das war halt auch mal etwas
mit mir zu tun hat und dass unsere
demokratie diese mühe eben wert ist und
ich kann für mich sagen es gibt doch
eher wenn man sich irgendwie für unsere
gesellschaft für politik für dieses land
interessiert und ich sage dass ich
jemand der wahlen gecovert hat bei denen
menschen sich in die luft gesprengt aber
den leuten ihr leben riskiert haben uns
wie es gibt doch nichts schöneres als an
diesem sonntag vom wahllokalen zwischen
vehlen fantastisch und die gehe wirklich
auch immerhin aber ich meine halt dass
man also ganz grundsätzlich die
briefwahl in zweifel zu ziehen ich
glaube aber dass wir uns wahrscheinlich
eh einig das ist also dann kann man muss
dann über die konditionen sprechen eben
also wie viel zeit kann davor vergehen
also das ist ein vier wochen sind und
was meine frau berg hat noch fünf
fehlern im lebenslauf oder soll ich hab
mir oder dann kann die dann stört ja
genau oder war hat wirklich einfach der
anderen seite punkt oder eine partei
stellt plötzlich noch einmal
interessant der interessante punkt von
klaus ist doch dass gleich und gleich
hat ja das kann man ja finde ich sehr
schlüssig argumentieren durchaus etwas
mit gleichzeitig zu tun ich habe gleich
viel zeit für meine thesen so war das
ein totaler briefwahl heute ist
vermutlich das arbeite lange von einem
guten vorschlag gehört wie seinen muss
ich sagen ich wundere mich dass darüber
nicht viel offenheit und öffentlich
diskutiert wird denn sie haben gesagt
das hat was auch mit ein bisschen mühe
zu tun da hinzugehen das sehe ich gar
nicht die das wahllokal ist im regelfall
zwei straßen weiter höchstens man geht
dann macht den kleinen spaziergang hin
es ist ein ritual sondern das meine ich
dann ja ja ein ritual oder geplante
ausstellung mit ihren stimme ich überein
außerdem geht es natürlich auch um ein
paar andere vokabeln zu bringen es geht
um würde des wahl- aktion würde der
demokratie und dem respekt vor den
ganzen vorgang und das ist doch spannend
zu sehen wenn man da im wahllokal steht
dass man da mit allen möglichen menschen
zusammen steht die sind an dem tag alle
gleich und sehen sich und man sieht die
menschen die sich die mühe macht diesen
vertritt zu zählen eben diesen zettel an
darüber zu schieben damit jemand anderes
was man isst doch mal wechselten wort
mit den wahlhelfern und fragt wie viele
waren denn schon da und wenn man daraus
gehen dann rechnungen ja wenn man
rausgeht hat man sich ein erhabenes
gefühl man hat was sind fdp wähler
eigentlich wie viele auch aber nicht nur
und viele haben auch respekt vor dem
wahlakt sie steht als gerade ehrenamt
wahlhelfer ganz wichtig aber ich glaube
wir haben wir haben insgesamt in der
gesellschaft so eine haltung ein
bisschen demokratie als versandhaus zu
sehen zu konsumieren ja mal so viel wenn
am wenn am sonntag gutes wetter ist dann
macht man was anderes geht nicht zur
wahl oder geht macht vorher briefwahl
also ich glaube es ist genau die frage
würde respekt des wahlamtes andere
menschen in der welt werden prüfen sie
es dürften und das ist bei uns einfach
zu sehr routine geworden sehr gut wird
eigentlich alle vier jahre auf diesem
stichtag genau nicht auch gewählt damit
es eben genau diesen diesen stichtag
moment gibt damit man eben genau diese
zeit hat jetzt dahin zu argumentieren
dass die idee ja aber wofür also wie
viel prozent briefwähler werden dann für
dich noch in dem bei 60 70 80 gesagt
eben eine mehrheit ist wahrscheinlich
wirklich dann ein demokratiepolitisch
bedenklich aber solange es nicht an den
60 kratzt wie gesagt vor allem jetzt in
diesen zeiten kann es mir so für die das
schwer beurteilen weil durch corona ob
wir jetzt games sind und uns das immer
so viel ausmacht ist okay aber es gibt
jetzt trotzdem noch viele menschen die
honorare sind lustig machen wollen und
können und die verstehe aller gemeint
ich jetzt genauso und ich bin wie gesagt
auch ein sehr ich finde ich fantastisch
trotzdem würde es gerne jedem einzelnen
überlassen obers machen will ich
vielleicht gibt es menschen die das
nicht zu sehen und die gerne einfach
liebe diesen brief abschicken warum auch
immer und die wird sich nicht absprechen
wollen das war ja mal anders in
deutschland bis 2008 glaube ich war das
nicht möglich es sei denn man war
habgier der gründung also nicht ja
nochmals ich habe nach meinen dass ich
das wieder eine theorie zur briefwahl
ich glaube es finden besonders die leute
brief war toll die bei oma gerne die
grünen freuen ja also ich habe das
gefühl dass das bein ein ganz großes
phänomen geworden ist von leuten die
gerne für ihre familie entscheiden
wollen die täten überprüfen wollen und
ist dann auch übrigens noch dritter oder
beim betrunkenen sohn der erst spät nach
hause gekommen dass die cdu an herrschte
schon so laschet aber das ist schon also
bei der beide an der urne an der
wahlurne wird tatsächlich sehr streng
geprüft ob ich da alleine das ist ja was
flächendeckend wegfällt auf einmal da
wird dann am frühstückstisch auf einmal
und ich muss sagen sehr gruselig war die
momente erleben das ja schon wenn bei
der auszählung von stimmen auch bei
ausländischen wahlen dann gesagt wird da
kommen aber noch die die
briefwahlstimmen dazu entweder sehen die
schon ausgezählt keiner weiß aber mit
welchem ergebnis darf er noch nicht
gesagt werden oder sie werden erst
später ausgezahlt den usa haben wir das
gesehen aber der bei der tramp abwahl
spielt das eine relativ große rolle ja
das ist so heller und durchschaubar was
sich da abspielt ob die genau richtig
bei denen war es die frage sind sie
genau richtig gezählt das muss wird man
sich das problem seien aber dass es da
etwas gibt dass wir nicht kennen das
nicht gleich zugänglich ist dass wir
nicht gleich verstehen dass irgendwann
dazu kommt finde ich ganz schrecklich
wer von euch hat schon mal briefwahl
gemacht ich hab mich war immer da jemand
anriefen habe schon mal gemacht weil ich
mich da war ja man muss jetzt auch mal
in österreich werden also ist österreich
für wen würde dieses thema im moment wer
vorhat briefwahl gerade mehr zu fürchten
ist das ist das los und ist na ja weil
es bei den usa die frage also wem nutzt
liefert eigentlich mehr in den usa was
hier ganz klar joe biden der lack trump
erst ganz deutlich vorn und die beiden
leute haben immer gesagt wartet ab blues
hat das kommt auch wenn die
briefwahlstimmen ausgezählt werden ja
also ich finde es auch ein wichtiger
unterschied was wir gerade besprochen
haben respekt vor dem eigentlichen wahl
akt von dieser wirklichen
gleichzeitigkeit einerseits aber auch
nicht stimmung machen das macht die afd
misstrauen bewusst jetzt zusehen dass
generell briefwahl instrument sei
irgendwie wahlen zu manipulieren und das
eben ein schmaler grat ich finde wir
müssen genauer den respekt sie würde
wieder stärken dass die wertschätzung
für diesen wahl akt und dass wir da
diese mitbestimmungsmöglichkeiten der
aktuell vorne liegt
wer jetzt für scholz ja wenn alle
schulen zu alarmieren landes beherrschen
wahrscheinlich lasche noch erreichen
kann wird ja durch briefwahl immer
kleiner sozial sie haben sich also diese
entwicklung schon festgelegt ja alle
anderen die sagen wir haben wissen schon
was wir verändern
jung galt aber die die gewählt haben
sind der schon festgelegten diesem schon
in ordnung das übrigens finde ich für
die demokratie nach wie vor als der
schlimmsten worte dass man seine hoch
heilige stimme in einem rohen valoren
jetzt also das ist für mich das habe ich
ja das wird schwer insofern ist
briefwahl warum einmal die spd so auf
briefwahl gesetzt warum haben diese
aktivierungs kampagne so passiv gefahren
die scheinen dazu glauben dass benutzer
laschet im moment so lasch dasteht oder
eben genau aus dem grund weil es könnte
jetzt doch noch was ändern und diese
stimme ist eingeholt erst genau und
wahrscheinlich lehrer die die spd wählen
angst damit sogar zu gehen wenn die
krone oder sowie hat also das heißt zu
ordnen sich alte anhängerschaft
inzwischen dies vielleicht weiß ich
jetzt nicht genau soziologisch aber
älter als die von anderen parteien und
das muss gleich organisiert werden damit
man den die scheune fahren kann fand ich
übrigens apropos alte wählerschaft sind
total spannende punkt zew- umfrage haben
wir vorhin kurz drüber gesprochen der
kandidat der unter seinen eigenen wlan
beim trial am schlechtesten
abgeschnitten hat auch da armin laschet
in den niedrigen 70ern olaf scholz und
annalena baerbock beide über 80 und aus
meiner sicht auch absolut dramatisch
dass die älteren wähler segmente in
dieser umfrage nicht mehr cdu wählen wie
kommt es dazu das schlimmste im sport
ist wenn deine eigenen fans dich
ausbuhen
das ist das was sozusagen armin laschet
jetzt erlebt wie wenden sich ab und ich
weiß nicht was aus meinem eigenen
bekannten geist und und ein
freundeskreis das wirklich hart gesotten
unionswähler irgendwie sowas sagen wie
also dann werden wir diesmal halt grün
das htc manche
das ist wird zwar furchtbar sehr an sich
sind aber wenn dann wäre dann machen wir
es jetzt mal bloß damit dieser mann
sozusagen mich kanzler wird weil das
galt auch für die us bonität also die
einfache zeigen die bereits völlig sind
aus diesem effekt die stimmen für für
grün und auch die fdp praktisch messbar
abschließende frage an goalie lloris und
andere schneider sie sind partei klaus
arbeitet hier ich auch wer gewinnt die
wahl der bundeskanzler muss ich mir
jetzt festlicher zwei einfache worte
sebastian kurz
ich würde wirklich alle oder chance olaf
scholz leiter ist dann sage ich auch
stolz seit gestern sagt auch ulrich
jörges olaf scholz zwei einfache worte
[Musik]